you can take a brain pattern of a 10
year old and predict whether that brain
belongs to a boy or a girl about 93
percent of the time almost as good as
you can by looking at an adult face of a
male and female so huge difference
why do you think the discussion about
sex differences between men and women
has become so hotly contested recently
yeah great great question I I think it's
always been hotly contested to some
extent
um it just kind of flares up and then
down just depending on conditions I I I
think the the
one of the main drivers is there are
um
many individuals who don't want to
believe that there's biological bases to
anything and if there's a biological
basis to anything it it's going to show
up in in sex differences
and there are um gender activists who
don't want to believe that there are
differences between men and women that
have a biological basis to them and
therefore they don't want to
consider that those potential
differences contribute to socially
important outcomes like the percentage
of males and computer science or
engineering or you know teaching or
whatever it might be
and so you did a bunch of research right
looking at stem uh and
seeing what it was that contributed to
uh women's lower participation in stem
subjects
right yeah so so we looked at
um we we've looked at a variety of sex
differences and a number of things and
in one um 2018
study we looked at the um proportion of
women college students who were getting
degrees in inorganic Sciences so
computer science engineering physics and
so forth and
um we
plotted that against things like gender
equality which is uh would be a high
gender equal country would be one that
they tend to be generally pretty wealthy
liberal
um there's high levels of female
participation in the labor force there's
women in Parliament or Congress or
whatever
um it might be a lot of women in higher
ed and so forth so the standard argument
has been for the last uh four or five
decades is that as countries approach
that type of
um wealth and liberal openness that
basic psychological cognitive and other
sex differences will begin to disappear
so so we looked at that generally we
looked across countries and we found the
exact opposite of that that as countries
became more gender equal they were as
proportionately fewer women going into
these inorganic Sciences they were going
into other areas
um presumably so the Gap in these um
these particular stem Fields actually
increased as societies became more open
to women participating in a variety of
kind of cultural endeavors
have you got any idea whether this is
due to interests or abilities
right probably a cup a couple of
different things
um interest for sure
um there are sex differences in
um interest in science generally and
there are sex differences in
particularly interest in uh mechanical
um types of things how how inorganic
things work
um in terms of abilities
the probably one of the primary movers
is intra-individual strength
so if you're
interested so what what are you best at
reading or math or reading or science or
whatever it might be and throughout the
world girls are generally their best
subject is generally reading meaning
that their comparative advantage is in
fields that are more reading heavy than
math or science heavy even if their
overall levels of math and science are
high or even higher than boys
um if their strength is reading they're
still more likely to go into other
fields uh than than STEM related that's
very interesting that it's not
necessarily you could have let's say
that um
women were better than men in uh maths
on average
but that women were even more better at
reading they're going to be predisposed
to do the thing that they are best at we
all take pride in the things that we
feel we're very competent at and if we
have this biological predisposition that
is a sexed difference why why would it
be surprising that we would go away and
and flourish in those areas well yeah it
is not actually surprising at all
um you know in in our mind uh because it
it's just a rational Choice you're going
to go into areas in which you're going
to have a comparative advantage where
you're going to do relatively better
than you would in other areas so if
you're a poor reader and you're
reasonably good at math and science
you're probably going to go into a tech
field
um if you're really good at reading and
much better at reading than than Tech
related sorts of things you're probably
going to go into Humanities or something
similar
why is it the case or why would it be
the case that females are better at
Reading and that males seem to be better
at maths give me the ancestral
justification for why uh men should be
better at counting things and women
should be better at reading things given
that both of those have only been around
for a few thousand years
right yeah so so both reading and
Mathematics are evolutionarily novel
abilities and so you can't say that well
you know women uh you know evolve to be
good readers and Men evolve to to do
math it just just doesn't make sense and
you know probably if anything the good
mathematicians and recent evolutionary
history probably have had below average
reproductive success uh you know just
wild guess there
um but in in terms of reading if you
look at brain Imaging studies and
cognitive studies and so forth it is an
adaptation of the language system
and other systems like theory of mind
you know understanding characters and so
forth understand plots
um
and women have advantages in certain
language areas and they have advantages
and theory of mind and so forth so the
underlying basis
upon which reading skills are developed
there's a sex difference favoring girls
and women when it comes to math uh
there's no math Gene per se I mean there
is a kind of inherent sense of quantity
and so forth but it's not a very
sophisticated skill
um
and if we look at overall mean
differences in math they're pretty small
where we see the differences are in
areas that involve spatial abilities
so certain areas of geometry solving
word problems actually has a spatial
component to it because you can sketch
out their relations in a complex word
problem that helps you kind of solve set
up and solve that problem
um and and that is driving the sex
difference in in math levels
to a large extent when when we see those
differences
there are also more men than women at
the high end of math performance that
was at one point a very big gap it's
closed since the 90s so maybe three to
one men than women at the high end
um but it's kind of been relatively flat
since then I would imagine
it seems to me that the discussion
around
we need to get more women into stem we
need to get more men in to heal
has very much dampened down
as the Stark difference in College
admission and then uh like completion
rate between women and men with two
women for every one man completing a
four-year us college degree ish on
average seven times more men dropped out
of college during covid than women uh
it's it's huge um I noticed that the
discussion around uh pushing women
further into higher education appears to
have kind of Fallen by the wayside we
haven't we haven't had that uh be quite
so vociferous uh as it was and that
seems to have been I would have said in
the last sort of three to four years uh
that I've really noticed it yeah yeah
the um you know if we go back that
there's a long literature on um kids
liking of school you know going back
more than 100 years and and girls have
always kind of liked School more than
boys
um sitting there listening to adults and
you know being conscientious doing I
mean that's more
uh it's easier for girls to adapt to
that kind of environment than it is
especially for young guys they just are
not really it's not really their thing
um and as higher ed opened you know
there there were clearly restrictions on
in discouragement of women going into
college
um going back 60 years
or so is those restrictions abated we
had more women flowing into higher ed
than men and now we have about a 60 60
40 ratio of completion
um for uh in in the U.S and a lot of um
Western
countries
yeah so bringing attention to that
um highlights the disadvantage that boys
and men now have in educational outcomes
and that might be why
um you don't hear as much about it
because
um the gender activists don't want
people to think about it
but it's it's a problem it's a problem
on multiple levels one is it's
distorting the operational sex ratio for
young adults more educated women than
men leads to more competition among
women uh for a smaller base of educated
and ambitious do you know what I've I've
deemed that I needed to come up with a
meme to describe that so I've deemed it
the tall girl problem
tall girl problem yeah yep and it's um
you know it it's associated with the
delays in marriage
um you know increased divorce rates uh
more objectification more sexy selfies
more casual sex more unprotected sex
right right you know back back back to
the hippie and disco days types of
things for young educated
um adults
yeah you know which is whatever I I used
to blame it on the Bee Gees but
apparently it's a little more
complicated than that you know you've
got the the sex ratio uh thing or or or
the tall girl thing tall girl problem it
is yeah the other problem is is that
um the US and and a number of other
highly developed countries are losing
the industrial base that would
um provide pretty good paying jobs for
working class guys
that really got them integrated into the
uh Workforce integrated into the broader
culture so forth and now a lot of those
jobs are disappearing and you have a lot
of guys that are probably pretty good at
spatial mechanical types of things but
they're not
pursuing school and a lot of them are
pulling back is a huge number work you
know living at home still not really
engaged socially not engaged
economically and it you know it it's a
potential Tinder Box for society if if
you know things really really collapse
economically
you are touching on all of my favorite
catastrophes and crises here David so
first one
um Richard Reeves book of boys and men
were you familiar with that did you get
to read that last year
I don't think I I've read that you would
it's very short super short read only
about 150 200 pages I think fantastic so
it's um here's a policy wonk guy from
Washington DC who is looking at
structural issues that boys and men are
facing uh education employment and then
in the home you would love that so first
off put that on your list secondly
Nicholas eberstat men without work are
you familiar with him no no
yeah I I yeah sorry I I've read the
basic economic papers but not the
popular press books got you yeah so his
um he was on the show a couple of weeks
ago and he said there's this cohort of
prime working aged 22 to 55 year old men
seven million of which are unemployed
and not seeking work on average they
spend 2 000 hours per year Watching
screens 50 of that time is on
prescription drugs or whilst smoking
weed and two-thirds of that cohort live
in a household which claims at least one
disability benefit right right
absolutely wild huge huge problem uh
that is a huge problem I mean partially
due to the changes you know increases in
world trade and changes and as I said
that the manufacturing base
um I I also wonder if a lot of the
cultural social rhetoric about things
like toxic masculinity and so forth and
promoting girls in education which is
fine
um but it's often seen by activists as a
zero-sum sort of game you don't want to
acknowledge any issues that boys have
because that might take away from what
girls are the extras that girls are
getting and it's creating a real problem
I couldn't agree more um one thing that
you touched on before was the potential
Tinderbox and uh
let's roll all of these together given
the fact that we have the highest rates
of sexlessness amongst young men that
we've ever seen around about 30 of men
haven't had sex in the last year aged 18
to 30. around about 50 percent of men
say that they're not looking for
short-term or long-term relationships we
have this massive cohort around about
seven million men just in the US 22 to
55 that are not looking for work not um
and also not employed also not in
education employment or training
and yet we haven't seen the in-kind
increase of
killings and anti-social Behavior spray
painting cars setting stuff on fire
pushing over granny Etc right what do
you attribute the fact that young male
syndrome has all the raw materials to
occur and yet we haven't seen it what do
you think is going on there right yeah
yeah well typically as as you said when
you have these disaffected disengaged
men you get higher rates of crime and
violence and a variety of other
um social ills I I think you hit on it I
mean they have something to keep them
occupied they've got internet porn or
whatever they're watching on on the
screens and they're getting some flow of
income either from disability payments
or extended unemployment or they're
living with their parents or something
like that so they are kind of marginally
satisfied probably with with things but
um you know what happens if you know the
US and these countries go into a massive
recession and these benefits and other
sorts of things have to be cut and you
know it's basically they're being paid
off
uh to be quiet and just deal with their
situation oh that's a very interesting
way to frame it there is
um some existential malaise just this
ambient sense that you're not needed uh
structurally socio-culturally uh
archetypally in terms of the role that
you play in The Wider World
um and the
how would you say Rich social safety net
financially that a lot of men are
offered it doesn't allow them to buy a
palace but it gives them enough money to
keep the pawn uh subscription and the
internet taking over uh which means that
social media can continue to sedate
Video Games
Etc Etc yeah I think um right where I've
arrived at is a sedation hypothesis that
you've got porn video games social media
that are kind of
um
nursing the desire for status seeking
for goal orientation and for
reproduction and giving them a titrated
dose this is enough means that they
don't need to go and do it therefore the
lack of it doesn't hurt quite so much
it's not enough to be satisfied but it's
enough to not go and burn everything
down
um
foreign
I mean this is the this is a problem
that I'm I'm basically completely
obsessed by at the moment um one one
other thing to to just kind of round out
what we spoke about at the beginning
is that the gender equality Paradox is
that what we're referring to the fact
that as you get increasing
egalitarianism you have more of a sex
difference in terms of what people go
into
right yeah yeah so so that we we call it
the gender equality Paradox and stem uh
in this particular article
um but you also see larger sex
differences in a variety of other things
such as personality spatial abilities uh
a variety of things that it you know as
people get wealthier and there are more
options social and economic options
available to them
um they're better able to express their
own individual preferences and we've
argued that as you're better able to
express your own individual preferences
any inherent sex differences or any
inherent individual differences will be
better expressed in those contexts than
his contacts that re that
um uh have for a variety of reasons more
restricted opportunities so as the real
world constrains your choices less by
being more free more open more degrees
of freedom more opulent Etc that allows
you to fully follow whatever it is that
you care about the most therefore these
sex differences we seem to see increase
right yeah what is the response from
sex difference denial
groups about why the gender equality
Paradox exists then
well um yeah when when we uh uh he's so
Ed and I did this you know that this
2018 study you know I I we walked
through got through all the data and we
thought it was pretty interesting
but not you know we didn't think it was
going to be as big at least I didn't
think it was going to be as big of a
deal as it turned out to be mostly
because it wasn't that surprising and it
wasn't that surprising because other
people had found like increases in
personality differences and so forth
across cultures
um but our uh but the response to it was
pretty
um negative we we got a lot of emails
um the editors of the journal apparently
got a lot of emails including
um
you know attacks on us and pressure for
them to retract the article so forth
they they didn't do that
um there there was a commentary on it
that did get published I think just
because the editor got tired of getting
so many commentaries he finally say well
we're already published one and we're
not gonna do any others
um that showed that the gender equality
Paradox didn't well one they they
complained about how we Define
proportion of males and females in stem
fields which was just kind of kind of
dog you know I I know you know just kind
of a stupid thing
um but then they
took actually in a study that he's born
and I put together called the the biggie
which was an alternative
um measure of well-being and sex
differences and well-being rather than
the gender
um equality measure that most people
look at we looked at things like
opportunities to complete education
overall healthy lifespan life
satisfaction things that are
um equally valid for men and women and
boys and girls rather than something
like
the proportion of women in Parliament
which has a gender activist and it's
it's very female biased so when we use
the female biased measure
which is what the activists push for and
is a better measure of gender equality
we get the Paradox when we look at our
measure which we developed to make it
sex neutral just because the gender
equality stuff is biased
um they don't find that which is
what we we would expect but in anyway
the authors of that made a big deal of
that
they did a hit piece on he's bird and
eye and BuzzFeed
um oh very reputable
academic response there yeah I I had
never read BuzzFeed I never even
considered it you'll be parked in
between four outfits to wear on your
next hot girl walk and 10 dog memes so
good that we can't stop laughing so I'm
glad that they really positioned you
appropriately that right right well they
they put in there a lot of AD homine and
a lot of
comments that the editor and reviewers
of their comment to the journal said you
got to take out because this isn't
supported they put it in there but
anyway now there's this BuzzFeed thing
and there's this uh commentary on our
original article
so when people bring up the gender
equality Paradox and stem
you they can now say well this has been
debunked see this BuzzFeed
see this [__] off dude [__] off yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so that's that's how it's dealt with you
know you get something into the General
Media in a commentary somewhere or some
counter argument
somewhere and then when somebody brings
it up you don't have to discuss the
points you can just say well that's
already off the table it's gone it's
been uh you know the top speed at Al
2018. yep yep phenomenal okay um one
final thing to sort of round this out
you've used uh the participation in stem
that seems to be you know a very obvious
sex difference that occurs as you get
more egalitarianism in in a society
are there any other equally strong or
even stronger evidence for the gender
equality paradox
well uh one one interesting thing is the
um
sex difference in height gets bigger
um what which sounds weird yeah yeah
and that that has nothing to do with
gender equality actually it has to do
with the overall health of the
population the wealth of the population
medical
um yeah oh so using in a in a less
prosperous
uh less egalitarian society or a less
prosperous Society egalitarian societies
tend to need to be prosperous in order
to be able to allow people to choose
what they want prosperous societies have
better medical interventions Food Water
Sanitation Etc which doesn't
Nerf the height increases that men's
natural genetic disposition would have
caused them to get am I right here
that's correct the physical sex
differences get bigger
um because the overall health of the
population gets better and so not only
are the psychological sex differences
expressed better the physical sex
differences are actually larger that
that's a very robust effect
and I'm looking now at whether that
particular fact is correlated with
changes in sex differences in certain
cognitive abilities suggesting that as
physical health gets better you know the
brain obviously is going to mature
better and fully developed to its full
potential
um then some cognitive sex differences
should actually increase along with the
sex differences and height
and
um it's hard to study that a little bit
because there's really good data on
height across you know the last century
in a lot of countries and some places
across multiple centuries
um but the you know the psychological
cognitive tests are more recent so there
isn't as good a data but but but there's
hints of that
um the spatial advantages of men in
spatial abilities seems to be increasing
along with their increases in height
and the and and it and it often is uh
positively correlated with um the
overall health of the population so
healthier populations with bigger sex
differences in height usually have
bigger sex differences in
um spatial abilities
uh the same seems to be true with
women's advantages in certain verbal
memory tasks and episodic membrane
personal experiences and so forth
they're better at those and as
indicators of overall physical health
get better
um the sex difference there seems to
increase as well so that ties it into if
we tie it into height changes
um we can better link it to actual an
actual biological mechanism David you're
absolutely blowing my mind here this is
so interesting so
um in the same way as a prosperous
society allows men and women to better
choose the life path that they have
it may also
um biologically nutritionally medically
Etc create a foundation that allows men
and women to be more of what they are
with regards to their cognition their
capacity uh their behavior which
is Upstream from a society that allows
them to choose what they want to do more
so it predisposes them to a particular
type which would be women I I imagine
you know if you were able to do the best
studies in the world you might even find
that women's social networks become more
intricate they become
um more nuanced and more subtle in
particular ways
um
this is like this is one of the most
interesting things that I've learned
this is really really really cool
um
yeah they're they're there are some
interesting Behavioral Studies looking
at
um in developing nations looking at
things like um
uh Nutritional Health nutritional
supplements for kids who are
um at risk for stunting you know kind of
low physical growth poor poor physical
growth and so you can look at behavioral
competitiveness
um physical activity levels which
generally favor boys over girls and you
can look at you know how to supplements
you know how does improving their health
change these sex differences and Rough
and Tumble play competitiveness and so
forth
and the biggest gains are for boys who
are receiving these supplements and
um the biggest losers are the boys who
don't get them so some of the sex
differences in you know just physical
activity levels and and competitiveness
um are smaller or disappear in
malnourished you know poor health kits
but when you improve their health these
sex differences pop up
that's fascinating yeah yeah consistent
with you know there there's a biological
Foundation to this that is rooted in um
you know physical health in including um
you know brain development
when it comes to sex differences in
cognition what are the most
well-established differences in men's
and women's Brains let's get into the
nuts and bolts of what's actually going
on here sure so let's um you know
traditionally psychologists have been
studying sex differences in cognition
for you know a century or so
um and they focused on verbal abilities
generally math and spatial let's take
math off the table because it's
evolutionarily novel it's not that
interesting and inverbal is a Big Field
it can go anywhere from you know how
quickly you can name animals that start
with the letter a
um versus analogical reasoning you know
girls have advantages and one Boys on
another so it's it's not not clear so
putting it I I've argued that we you
know we really need to think about these
cognitive sex differences from a broader
evolutionary perspective and think about
okay what is it that is universal
um across people no matter where they
live you know math isn't because you get
it in school or you don't get it at all
um and so things that are one thing that
is universal that women and girls have
advantages on or something that I call
at least an aspect of folk psychology
these are skills that allow you to
interact with individuals on a one 101
basis and more importantly develop and
maintain one-on-one relationships this
would be you know BFF sorts of
relationships you think about all the
skills involved in that
and that would be you know language is
obviously a good part of it but also
reading facial expressions you know
making inferences about how they're
feeling or thinking based on facial
expressions reading body posture types
of things vocal intonation theory of
mind which is your skill is actually
figuring out what's going on with the
individual
and if we look at each of those
individual skills girls and women have
small to moderate advantages in them
but in the real world they're working in
concert
they're not just bits and pieces they're
they're working all together and if we
look at the entire constellation of
skills as they're working together in an
interaction or interpreting an
interaction girls and women have fairly
large advantages probably about 85
percent of them are better than the
average guy or maybe 90 or so so it's a
fairly substantial Advantage there are
other areas involved in you know dealing
with with people or groups or whatever
where we see more subtle differences but
it's the the one-on-one kind of
emotional intelligence I think some
people might call it that I think that's
what people mean by that I call it kind
of an individual level folk psychology
girls girls and women do really well at
that
um boys and men
do particularly good on what I call folk
physics
this is is not an academic physics but
it is kind of the foundation for aspects
of of an academic physics it involves
things like
um dealing with the physical world uh
navigating from one place to another
tracking the trajectory of things as
they're moving
um through space
um understanding how objects might be
manipulated and used as tools a
mechanical reasoning type of thing
and so boys and men
um have small to large advantages in in
all of those areas
wow okay what social learning theory
social learning theory well there is a
social learning theory where we learn to
um you know what do you do in this
context you know you go to a dinner with
folks you know it's your first formal
dinner you've never worn a tie before
and you have no idea how to do things
you know you watch other people and you
figure out you kind of imitate
um what people who seem to know what
they're doing are doing and so that's a
social learning type of thing and and
and that's a universal as well I mean we
learn a lot from other people there's no
doubt about that but I I think it might
be mean social roles theory yes yes yeah
so social roles is the
um argument that
uh boys and girls and men and women
learn to behave in sex specific ways you
know like girls are more communal or
nurturing and guys are more agentic you
know focused on getting things done
being more dominant and and so forth
because they receive either explicit or
implicit information from the social
environment that they are that basically
tells them oh you're a girl you're a boy
and this is what girls and boys do and
therefore you
adhere to these roles
and the argument then is that
um that's how all these we're basically
Blank Slate mentally psychologically and
then we kind of develop these roles
based from you know learning from others
of of the same sex
um and that is the argument underlying
things like
um you know encouraging girls to do this
getting Role Models you know girls in
stem Role Models which is fine I mean
whatever
um the problem is is it's it's
well overstated you know boys don't like
playing with toy cars and blocks and so
forth because their parents have
implicitly given them those toys for
Christmas or they've seen the
advertisements you know boys playing
with these things on television
um they like playing with these things
because uh you know if you're playing
with a car it is it has a specific type
of motion to it it's a non-biological
motion
that captures the attention of What's
called the dorsal visual stream that
feeds into these folk physics centers
that I
um mentioned uh previously so there is
an early bias in what boys and girls
look at boys look at physical motion and
stuff and they're attracted to those
types of things girls look at faces and
the details of objects
more and that's I mean there there is
some place for social roles but but it's
the extent of its influence is really
overstated in my opinion
a lot of people when they talk about sex
differences particularly whether that be
in children or as soon as people grow up
to be adults will come up against
somebody who either in terms of
well-meaning or this is just the way
that they see the world will use social
roles Theory as well look of course boys
are stronger than girls they're the ones
that are encouraged to do Rough and
Tumble play of course boys are more
interested in things than people because
they've seen it on TV of course boys are
expecting to be more dominant because
these are the subtle cues that their
parents and the media and everybody else
has given to them for the people who sit
down at Thanksgiving perhaps with that
one brother or sister or cousin who
makes it puts this across as an argument
what are the strongest rebuttals
that can uh dispel this particular myth
yeah so so there was well one these
differences are
um Universal I mean it's not just you
know the you know us upper middle class
families at Sea I mean you see it all
over the place
um but but one important piece of data
well there are a number of them I'll
tell you one and I'll tell you more if
you want
um there was a study done you know a few
decades ago that was a fairly
large-scale study looking at
um you know a couple hundred parents and
how they were socializing their kids
so there were some of them were
traditional parents you know they'd buy
the girls Barbies or dolls or whatever
and the boys you know car trucks and
other parents were more
um I don't know if they'd be Progressive
I mean they'd be called Progressive
today that back then they were hippies
or whatever they were they were they
they were non-traditional so they raised
their kids say okay you know girls can
play with with blocks and with
um toy cars and boys can play with dolls
and all that's fine it doesn't make any
difference
and then the researchers brought the
kids into the lab setting and said okay
is it okay for girls to play with trucks
and boys play with dolls those that were
raised in non-traditional families said
yeah yeah sure it's fine no problem so
their beliefs about what's okay and or
what's typical or not typical or
whatever uh mirrored to some extent what
their parents said
um but then when you cut them loose and
watch how they actually play
they still play in sex typical ways so
their beliefs about kind of what boys
and girls should do and their actual be
it was one thing but their actual
Behavior was sex typical there was no
difference between how boys from
traditional and untraditional families
played and same for girls
meaning that the kids are calling the
shots here
um they're creating their own
environments based on what they find
interesting and what they want to do
does this show up in primates as well
juvenile primates
yeah um Rough and Tumble play is
um pretty common in species where males
are bigger and more aggressive than
females and those are typically species
if we're looking at primates where
there's a lot of male male fighting and
competition in adulthood
clearly see that in humans if we look
you know in human history it's clearly a
lot of physical competition a lot of
violence and and so forth
um the sex differences in physical size
go back at least four million years in
our ancestors it's a long long
evolutionary history of that obviously
males and females are big males are
bigger than females and modern humans
and we see the sex difference in um
Rough and Tumble plight I mean it just
fits very very nicely with this
evolutionary pattern in this pattern of
uh male on male aggression I remember
hearing a while ago that if you give a
juvenile female chimp perhaps a sort of
a soft toy that resembles a baby that
they treat it in a different way to the
males is that right was that have I made
this up or was that correct that's
that's correct it was with vervet
monkeys and I think it's been replicated
in you with with macaques or so so right
if if you give toys you know sex typical
toys the human sex typical a doll in a
truck you know big like dump truck that
that they they can play with
um you do see preferences the the the
females like the dolls more than the
males do
um the males are also more likely to
approach their novel types of things and
so they're risk-taking
um is higher there
now there's no
um you know toy trucks and macaque
evolutionary history
um but again it it could be attractive
because of the type of motion in the
dorsal ventral stream associated with
navigation and just kind of focusing on
large-scale space I'm fascinated by the
fact that um the type of toys it's not
it's not just the fact that that
figuratively represents a kind of uh
role perhaps that I would imagine that
if you were to look at the sex
differences in the trucker community
that it's going to be heavily skewed
toward men
um but it's there's also something
innate about that movement back and
forth and given the fact that we you
know go back far enough and we do have a
common ancestor there has to be the sex
difference which at least was maybe
there before we split off and we're
seeing this play out with macaques or
whatever else it might be
um
what what would you say to the people
that say we are more similar than we are
different you know if you look at the
overlap between the dispositions that
boys and girls have that men and women
have
um you know you've mentioned there at
one particular example which seems
pretty Stark which is the average female
is better than 85 percent of men when it
comes to I think it was reading faces or
perhaps it was verbal ability
um what would you say to people that say
we're more similar than we are different
these sex differences are basically
small and it doesn't really matter and
David you're just making a mountain out
of a molehill yep yep yep um I've heard
that and and that's a very popular
belief in um in in the field and in one
that is debated
so if we look at sex differences in
certain verbal skills they're fairly
small so you can say well we're more
similar than different maybe 60 percent
of women are better than the average guy
um not big but my point was in in other
people's point is is if you put the
whole package together it's you know the
brain is an integrated system of uh you
know that pulls together abilities that
you use in Tandem and when you pull
together these networks of abilities
that it would include you know making
eye contact uh theory of Mind sort of
things vocal intonation and so forth
that's when you get very big differences
and that's kind of more of a real life
sort of thing so if if we look at
individual personality types of things
like um how sociable how much you like
just you know festive chatter and
talking to people in kind of the warmth
component being nurturing you know it's
a modest sex difference favoring girls
and women in this case
um but if we put together the whole
pattern of Personality we have much much
larger differences with not in this case
not much overlap uh because this is not
just like rolling a six once it's the
equivalent of rolling five sixes in a
row and that Suite of traits when bound
together Trends much more towards women
I had um I had Joyce Bennington on the
show at the start of the year and she
gave me a really interesting example I'd
love to know if you've looked at any of
this she spent forever uh studying
kindergarten kids playing and the games
that they play and she mentioned that if
you look at the sorts of games that boys
and girls play these are uh three four
years old I think maybe up to five years
old you know hasn't been a massive
amount of time for socialization to
occur especially in kindergarten this
may be if you're the eldest child or an
only child the first time that you've
actually got to spend any significant
period of time with other kids
and she said if you look at the language
they're using if you look at the games
that they're playing boys are
um
binding themselves together over shared
Warfare against Cowboys or aliens or
something else and if you look at what
girls are doing they are keeping
something alive it's a rabbit it's a
doll and the language as well that's
used is um again very different sex
differently what have you have you
integrated any of this the sort of
social game playing into your work too
yeah yeah yeah yeah of course yeah
Joyce's work is great I I really keep up
on it and uh like like reading it yeah
in um yeah that's uh called social
dramatic play
yeah so kids when they hit that age
begin to develop a richer imagination
so they can now imagine themselves in
different role-taking sorts of
um you know uh you know different
characters in these roles and then they
can now better integrate their roles
with the roles of their Playmates so
they're they're basically practicing
social interactions in different
contexts being you know the hero of
being a parent or whatever it might be
so it's it's an important component of
um development and the interesting thing
there is that the fantasies that boys
and girls as as Joyce stated uh develop
on their own
um differ quite quite dramatically and
uh in fact the the vocabularies of boys
and girls begin to differ in the second
year of life in terms of what they talk
about how so what do they talk about
you know so you know a stereotypical
things uh you know
unsurprisingly to me so 18 month old
girls are more likely to focus on
clothing
um and boys on um objects
and you know in terms of just kind of
free free discussion sorts of things but
but the boys integrating themselves into
a they typically integrate themselves
into larger groups Joyce probably talked
about this as well and these groups as
you said are in some type of conflict
with something you know the Indians or
dragons or whatever it might be and they
they're coordinating and integrating
their behavior together
that is in my opinion a component of
rough and tumble play I mean there's
individual Rough and Tumble play but
there's also coordinating your activity
so that you are more functional as a
group
and if we look at
um between group conflict and
traditional contacts and we look at it
historically it is coordinated
activities of males
fighting the coordinated activities of
other groups of males that's male male
competition it just goes beyond
one-on-one it goes to a group level type
of thing and these early play
differences that Joyce talked about
we've wrote about 20 years ago saying
that this is preparation for this the
boys are creating these groups because
these are the groups they're going to
grow up with and later in some cases
fight with or cooperatively hunt with
it makes complete sense to anybody with
a semi-functioning brain as to
ancestrally why
boys males would have this
predisposition for practicing Warfare
and why girls would be interested in
people they would be playing doctor or
drama or veterinarian or whatever
family
how does this manifest or what what is
happening that's causing this to
manifest we can understand why right we
can understand the ultimate reason for
why this is happening but what what is
it that's inside of a male that causes
him to think let's pretend that we're
fighting Cowboys
yeah they don't they aren't necessarily
thinking anything they're engaging in
things that they find fun
so if if we look at disorders or just
individual variation in either prenatal
exposure to testosterone or
um uh postnatal spikes the first six
months of Life there is a big spike in
testosterone so there's a second dose
there in addition to the prenatal dose
and and girls have some some fluctuating
exposure to estrogens during that
six-month period as well although it's
not it's more variable than with guys
but in in any case
um the these hormonal influences are at
least partly contributing to these sex
differences in play so girls who have
more had more androgens early in life uh
you know prenatally
um engage in have play behaviors that
are closer to boys than girls or they're
they're kind of in between those so so
it's a mix of of activities so there
there there's clear the hormonal
component to it and I think the way that
works is in terms of what captures your
attention
you know biological motion is probably
going to capture the intention you know
of a baby or something will capture the
attention of girls more than boys
whereas the you know the physical motion
is going to capture the attention of
boys more than girls all you have to do
is have kind of a small attentional bias
and built-in reward systems that will
kind of keep you focused on that and
keep you engaged in related activities
and then it can kind of build from there
so that the mechanism is heavily driven
by Androgen exposure to testosterone
primarily and that's one of the key
differences is there anything else going
on here is a protein folding in the
brain are there particular areas of the
brain that are
um larger smaller atrophied you know
hypertrophied in in one form or another
yeah I mean probably probably the there
are I mean there there are sex
differences in in certain very basic
areas of the brain associated with
aggressive sexual and and that type of
behavior
um and there are some really interesting
sex differences in overall patterns of
brain organization so if you look at uh
gray matter and white matter if you look
at one small part maybe there's no
difference or maybe there's a difference
and if there is a difference it's
probably not going to be huge on average
but if you look at the whole pattern of
the brain
um you get quite substantial differences
you can take a brain pattern of a 10
year old
and predict whether that brain belongs
to a boy or a girl about 93 of the time
almost as good as you can by looking at
an adult face of a male and female so
huge difference and that's fmri
that that would be MRI just just
structural differences what what people
really need to look at is the
um coordinated activity of brain areas
so certain brain areas that are linked
together are going to fire together
spontaneously and that kind of helps
build that Network
and um uh keep it kind of well
functioning
so if you look at those spontaneous
brain activity studies and there aren't
that many with really young kids yet but
there's at least one during the prenatal
period where you can put Mom in a
scanner and get
a brain activity indices of the fetus
and we see sex differences there in
brain activity patterns in about six
months prenatally
um and there there was a recent study
looking at
um I think was two and three month olds
also showing uh differences in in
spontaneous brain activity patterns but
exactly how those are related to some of
these sex difference we were talking
about we we don't fully know that yet if
it was 93 to 10 years old what is it at
six
three months prior to birth and six
months after birth
yeah they they didn't do that that was a
somewhat different technology and
approach and they didn't do those
particular analyzes probably it's going
to be smaller because probably the
differences get bigger
um with age but but they they didn't
look at it yet I think nine or ten is
the youngest that I've seen look at that
there there's a number of these studies
with adults and it gets up to 95 or so
do you know how accurate they could be
at predicting the sex of the embryo
though
oh yeah they they didn't do those
analyzes okay okay fine fine
um
evidently what the researchers are
amongst another a number of things
trying to achieve here is say well at
age nine and ten you have had you know
social social roles Theory comes back in
again perhaps you have been socialized
into a mode of thinking which has caused
structural changes in the brain these
structural changes then basically beg
the question by being the detector thing
that is supposed to be detected and
people say that's what a male brain
looks like because we have never seen a
male brain which hasn't been socialized
as a male brain despite the fact that
there are a wide variety of families
that raise children in traditional and
non-traditional Progressive and
non-progressive ways unless someone is
going to say somehow that the brain of
the embryo three months prior to being
born has somehow been socialized the sex
differences that we see and you know I'm
being uh like overly
um
explicit here to just really try and
Hammer the point home that there are
structural changes that manifest into
real world significant differences not
only in disposition not only in
um uh
tendency interest capacity
um there are it's a whole Suite of
things that occur and um David Buss
mutual friend of ours was recently on
Rogan and I knew I had it it was
absolutely adamant that uh Rogan was
going to bring up sex differences sure
enough as as was predicted that ended up
happening the most interesting thing
that I've learned about sex differences
in the last year is differences in
throwing accuracy amongst children can
you please red pill everybody that's
listening on the differences in throwing
accuracy amongst children sure so um
yeah so you find differences in throwing
accurate see throwing distance and
velocity so uh even in preschoolers boys
are throwing more uh they can throw
farther
um in with higher velocity higher speed
and so higher kinetic energy than girls
can uh it is it emerges very early uh as
I said the preschool years and becomes
extremely large by 19 early adulthood or
so where there's very little overlap
between uh men and women maybe a little
bit but not not much it is it is a very
big difference
it is correlated with
um differences you know the shoulders
are built differently the forearms are
longer in men relatively uh relative to
overall size in women that um that
difference is evident prenatally it is
associated with the sex difference in
this dorsal stream sort of thing the
ability to track moving objects you know
to hit something that's you have to have
the cognitive system in brain and
cognitive system in place in order to
hit something accurately
um and if somebody's throwing something
at you you want to be able to track it
coming in so you can dodge it oh yeah it
didn't you looked at a study to do with
how effective males and females are at
dodging projectiles coming at them what
can you tell us that study yeah so um
some people have argued that or in fact
the initial argument and maybe it's
still the argument that the male
advantage in throwing distance accurate
speed and all of that sort sort of thing
is due to Shared child care and male
hunting
um you know and of course there is a big
sex difference in hunting engagement in
um in in traditional context no no
question about that
um but in addition to that men are
better at dodging things
so in this particular study uh you
couldn't do it anymore but but the the
researchers I if I remember correctly
got one of these tennis ball shooting
machines
um and uh
decided to shoot him at undergraduates
um to see what would happen I'm sure the
professors had a fantastic time when
they were aiming it at the annoying
child in the the front row that keeps on
distracting them during their lectures
yeah yeah yeah would unfortunately we
can't do that anymore
um but it I'm I'm sure it was at fairly
low speed and you know so nobody would
get hurt and so if relatively easy task
and so they just looked at the number of
balls that could be blocked and Men
blocked most of them in fact there was a
ceiling effect
um in women were not as successful uh at
that and that's obviously a defensive
mechanism if other males are using
projectile weapons the ability to track
and Dodge that is an important component
of male male competition that's that's
when my argument's not which came
probably before hunting
what is the suite of traits that we're
talking about here when it comes to
throwing accuracy throwing velocity
dodging seeing things moving through the
air Etc yeah so yeah so so we have the
throwing component to it it has you know
the behavioral component actually
throwing something and hitting it
accurately
um it has physical components to it you
know the upper body upper body strength
is big sex difference there the
architecture of the shoulder and arms
there are um there's brain area
associated with motion detection
and integrating motion detection with
physical movements as in blocking
something or throwing something uh and
so there's brain and cognitive systems
involved there
um that you see physical systems the
behavioral component of the brain and
cognitive component and guys are better
on all of those components or at least
the most of them integrated together
um you get a quite quite a large sex
difference
so this learning that and it was
specifically the accuracy thing that
really drove it home to me uh is for me
now one of the more compelling
justifications for for us thinking about
transgender athletes in sport a lot more
carefully because everybody has heard to
death uh someone talking about how a
biological male shouldn't be able to
step into the ring with a biological
female after a year of estrogen and
testosterone suppression and then
punched their face into the ground like
you know that's it's self-evident and
a lot of the arguments that I've seen
stem exclusively from well we can reduce
Power by x amount by putting them on
this particular type of hormone blocker
testosterone and androgens aren't all
that drive power then someone comes back
and says well look at bone density look
at muscle mass look at all of the time
you've gone through puberty blah blah
blah that's that's done like it's
interesting I guess it was interesting
but it's no longer interesting to me
what is much more interesting to me are
the fundamental capability differences
especially when it comes to things like
accuracy because if let's say for
instance that you were to have a
biological male that is going into the
uh
what is it the baseball Envy
NBA no what's the what's the baseball
league called
is there a women's lead yeah well there
must be I'm oh yeah I've got to imagine
so but the same as a WNBA right okay so
let's say that male goes into WNBA
they're not taller they're not bigger
they're built the same uh on average as
the average female basketball player
because I would imagine that female
basketball players probably pretty tall
taller than me taller than you
um
but what we're saying is that there is a
fundamental capacity capability
difference that biological males have
with just the way that they see throwing
and spatial rotation generally not just
to do with the physicality of the
architecture of the shoulder changes in
forearm length Etc but the the way that
their brains are able to see the world
of throwing overall this also explains
to a degree why the WNBA may be
significantly less popular than the
men's division not because women are
smaller and something else and something
else but they have a predisposition that
is oh you could say um that male's
capacity is overclocked uh and it is um
supercharged comparatively with women so
this to me is the most or one of the
most compelling reasons because it gets
Beyond this sort of messy conversation
about power and it gets more into
fairness uh and it's why it's so
compelling and I've never really heard
anyone do a full Treatise on on this
area of transgender athletes in sport
what is it let's say that there was a
sport
um where you had to do line detection or
you had to manipulate different social
groups or you had to be able to detect
facial cues or something uh if you were
to have female to male transitioners in
that sport they're going to absolutely
dominate The League even if they have
taken testosterone for ages and they're
walking around with the socio-sexuality
through the roof and the the sex drive
really high or whatever I I just found
this it's really fascinating I think
this is really really interesting stuff
yeah yeah yeah some some of the spatial
differences and the perceptual
differences that I mentioned are more
strongly related to prenatal or an early
postnatal hormonal exposure than actual
circulating testosterone so you can the
men's circulating testosterone isn't
really highly correlated with their
spatial abilities but the earlier
exposure seems to be what's important
there so yeah you can decrease muscle
mass a little bit by reducing
testosterone but there's other things
you're not going to change that people
have as you said people haven't talked
about
how big are the differences between
navigating from one place to another
yeah good good question
um they are I I would say
they are
um you know most of them are kind of
contrived situations you know they're
moderate to large
I would say men are better you know just
kind of dead reckoning sort of thing you
know you start from some place and you
wander around in the woods and then you
try to figure out how to get your way
back without
you know explicitly just backtracking
the exact same way you were get the
quickest route back men are better in
that I don't remember the exact effect
size but it's it's it's it would be
noticeable
um difference uh map Reading is
different as well interest in maps is
different
we could see uh quite obviously why it
would be the case that men need better
spatial rotation they need better
navigation over a broad ranging kind of
distance because if you're going out and
on average men ancestrally hunted more
than women therefore wildebeest goes
from right to left I have spear
wildebeest plus spear plus throwing plus
trajectory plus how the [__] do I drag
this back home hashtag where is home as
well also
what about
female
um sex differences that give them
capacities that men struggle with and
also why would these be that what is the
evolutionary justification for why they
would have them yeah so so the sex
differences and the folks psychology or
emotional attention uh emotional um
intelligence that I talked about earlier
uh women have advantages in
um probably related to a couple of
things one of them is uh
uh women are and girls want to develop a
social support network
that for social emotional support and
social and other types of problem
solving men form networks as well but
they're usually task oriented or
competition oriented networks so if you
hang out with all your friends watching
you know the WNBA or the Super Bowl or
something maybe the Super Bowl will be
better
watching the Super Bowl and you were
this last time rooting for the Chiefs
all of you and they win you're all kind
of bonded together even if you didn't
talk about anything
during that time you drank beer and did
whatever you're going to do that's kind
of a shared activity
um that kind of helps link male groups
together and you can have lots of guys
there you can't you know doesn't have to
be limited to two people
um girls and and women form
relationships more based on the dyadic
interactions and the social and
emotional support talking through issues
talking about what's important to them
and so forth and
uh the the Dynamics of this are very
different between males and females I I
covered in my um my book on on sex
different differences but
one component of it is that to develop
and maintain these BFF relationships you
have to be very sensitive to the
emotional state of
um your girlfriend your your best friend
you have to read things and so forth she
may not want to really
bother you by talking about you know
problems with their boyfriend or Mom or
whatever that might be but you can pick
up that something is not quite right and
you know a lot more about her than guys
do about their friends saying oh you
haven't
trouble with your mom again is it such
and such a sort of thing so that's the
theory of Mind sort of thing you're
picking up subtle non-verbal cues
picking up on it that's exactly what the
girlfriend wanted you to do and that
engages you in in the talk that that
hopefully will help to resolve
um that type of issue so that emotional
intelligence is really important for
these relationships it's also important
for dealing with and matting out
something called relational aggression
so the movie uh Mean Girls
maybe maybe you've seen that so you know
kind of kind of [__]
um girl you know subtle put Downs
um gossip and spreading lies it it's
basically designed to disrupt the
um social networks of competitors
undermine their same-sex friendships and
make them unattractive to
um boyfriends that would be boyfriends
and
it is most effective if it's done in a
way that is plausibly deniable
that is you do it very suddenly you know
I'm really worried about so and so
because I think she's
seeing three guys or drinking a lot
yeah that that sort of thing
and so because it's more you know when
guys are mad at each other they'll make
eye contact and they'll push or yell I
mean you don't have to figure it out I
mean it's usually obvious
um if they're really upset but you have
to have these subtle social skills to
pick up on that relational aggression so
that you can counter it
um and so I think the combination of
relational and and also have these
subtle skills to use it to manipulate
other other people
um I think the combination of the the
social support friendships and the
competition female female competitions
relational aggression is really
um the basis for the female advantage in
these these skills it seems to me that
the heavier brow Ridge that men have the
bigger jaw the bigger hands these are
our weapons right this is how men would
have done their intersexual competition
it would have been uh into group Warfare
as well with different tribes etc etc
the ability to understand and manipulate
social dynamics language ability reading
facial expressions that is female
Weaponry in regard now it's also
defensive offensive uh affiliative
um you know coalitional all of that
um but I just I loved thinking about
conceptualizing things in this way that
because women on average weren't getting
into physical altercations because they
are more fragile sometimes could be with
child if they die the danger of the
child being on their own is
significantly higher therefore make sure
that you don't uh how would you say
explicitly obviously accusatorly do
something that could cause you to be on
the wrong end of a very sharp stick from
either the
husband of the woman that you just
pissed off or the woman herself right so
you need to be able to manipulate social
groups you need to be much more subtle
and you need to dance your way through
this you need to use coalitional uh
tactics you need to sow seeds of Discord
venting as an example of this
um and because of that you have to have
a predisposition you have to have these
capacities to be able to make yourself
capable whereas for men everything's out
in the open you got a problem let's sort
the problem out we don't need to have
that quite so much
um yeah yeah men men engage in
relational aggression too and they play
politics and some of them are very good
at it but the politics is to organize
large-scale groups for a collective
actions sort of thing rather than
manipulating the social dynamics within
a smaller kind of social
um network but but but yeah you're right
yeah you have to be very good at that
um to navigate all of these complex
social relationships in a way that
doesn't provoke retaliation
yes when it comes to the current trends
that we're seeing this increase in
transgender especially youths what's
your assessment of the situation why do
you think it is that we've had such a
rapid increase in that happening
right yeah so I yeah I wrote that
qualified article that that you
mentioned on that and if we look at it
historically
um well so what let's step back let's
look at uh brain patterns that I
mentioned before where you know you take
it a 10 year old you you can predict 93
of the time whether it's a boy or a girl
if you take an adult You can predict 95
of the time whether it's a man or a
woman
so the brain patterns for guys are kind
of bunched up in this area but there are
some individuals that kind of go out on
the curve so there are guys that have
female typical brain patterns
not a lot of them but they're there uh
and there are girls who have been women
who have male typical brain patterns
so it's not
you know kind of out of bounds to think
well you know maybe for whatever reason
um you know you didn't see the sex
typical shift in brain development for
for whatever reason so you're going to
get it would make sense that you you
know you have some guys who really like
girl things
um but they're kind of forced to be boys
and to do boy things and they would
develop gender dysphoria and the same
thing for some girls
and so if we look at
early
um
transsexual
um in individuals
they had a pattern of sex atypical play
so they you know the boys are playing
and liked girl things and so forth
expressed wanting to be a girl had this
uh dysphoria depression and discomfort
with being a boy or or a girl if it's
the the reverse of that in those
individuals if they're carefully
screened and so forth would be fairly
rare
but if they transition
um most of them do okay they're okay
with it so the detransition rates are
one or two percent so it's like yeah it
worked for them
but now jump forward to the last you
know well it started maybe 20 years ago
but especially the last 10 years
or so the number of individuals who are
claiming to be transgender has really
spiked
um Way Beyond the numbers you would
expect based on these brain patterns for
example
um and the demographics of these
individuals have changed as well
typically it was disproportionately more
men than women and they had a history of
gender dysphoria now we're getting more
women especially adolescents than men
and most of them as far as I know don't
I mean some of them do but a lot of them
don't have this history of gender
dysphoria and sex atypical play patterns
and other sorts of things that have
historically been reliable markers of
um
transgender issues and doing well with
with the transition if that's what they
they chose to do so there's been this
huge Spike as you know and
it's been argued that's social media has
has driven a lot of it
um and I I think that's right and I
argued that
um adolescent girls in particular may be
at risk for these negative social media
influences
um because during that time you know
early adolescence late adolescence
they're really trying to develop this
social support network
you know a couple of BFFs and feel
included and integrated and socially
supported and emotionally supported and
so forth that's a really important thing
now guys go through a similar thing
where they want to be part of a bigger
group that works together and so forth
um but the girl networks I think are
more
susceptible to social contagion and
going along with ideas that maybe aren't
a good idea just to fit in and to be
part of the group and not to get
excluded or rejected from the group
which is a bigger concern for girls than
it is for boys and I know so I think we
have a recipe for like combine that with
social media and all the media attention
General Media attention to these issues
it's now become a political signal
rather than a kind of a personal desire
it's like you support this because you
support for all Progressive sorts of
things or against it because you're
against all Progressive sorts of things
it's really
created an environment that I think is
going to be detrimental and is being
detrimental to a lot of
adolescents and young adults especially
girls
and this would explain why you have seen
a sex difference in the number of f to M
as opposed to M to F transitions or
desires for transition because
it you would presume that
um
there's a left-handedness argument that
gets used I'm not sure if you've heard
this used before
uh where
during the Middle Middle Ages people
that were left-handed were seen as more
likely to be witches so
um people hid the fact that they were
left-handed I think it was around about
two percent of people
few hundred years ago said that they
were whereas now it's around about 10 to
it's a teens percent I think of the
population that are left-handed uh so
the argument is when you stop demonizing
people for being their true self being
fully left-handed or being a male that
identifies as a female or vice versa um
that people open up that would be the
explanation for why you would see this
rampant increase the fact that we are
more as a society more accepting of it
but that wouldn't explain why you have
this massive increase in F to M as
opposed to M to F that's right this sect
difference appears to be explained away
largely by the raw materials that we
went through women's desire to fit in
their greater social cue
ability to absorb absorb that it also
explains why you don't have a completely
random distribution of people across the
entire United States you know one person
out of every 10 schools one girl out of
every 10 schools one male out of every
30 schools let's say across the US it's
five girls in one class that all sit at
the same table together during lunch
that's right yeah yeah you see these
clusters or in the one school district I
think 10 of the kids
um I don't remember what the male female
breakdown was uh claimed to be
transgender or non-binary or something
which which makes no sense the the other
issue that has changed is the um regret
and detransition rates are going up
from Fairly rare one two percent or so
to
um you know did depending on what you
look at the stopping of of hormonal
treatment can be you know one out of
three or or so so the the rates of
people kind of changing their mind is
going up suggesting that the transgender
of the dysphoria so forth wasn't really
related to that it was due to some other
other issue
what I find particularly fascinating and
kind of morbidly ironic about this
situation is that the biological sex
differences that men and women have are
providing the raw materials to cause
increasing volumes of men and women to
recant their own sex or at least their
own gender identity so it's almost like
a supply and demand of what's going on
is happening in a community of people
that deny that there are any sex
differences
yeah yeah
yeah yeah it it it it it it's a mess so
right so
yeah so you're you're saying that the
um adolescent women's girls
susceptibility to social Contagion
has a biological basis to it which I I
think it does
um and that biological basis makes them
more prone to claim that they're really
a guy
yeah it is
um it's amazing people can can spend
stories for sure
David Geary ladies and gentlemen David
I've absolutely adored this it's been
booked on the on my schedule for about
two or three months now and I've been
looking forward to it it's delivered
more than I could have hoped for
um first off what are you working on
next and then secondly where should
people go if they want to keep up to
date with your work right so
um related to sex differences keep up I
published a third edition of my book
male female
um came out in 2021 so it's it's pretty
pretty up-to-date and I'm pretty anal
about documenting things because I know
it's controversial and you gotta kind of
oversight things
um on the sex differences thing that the
thing I've been working on on and off is
I have spare time you know I've uh you
know other things to do is this um
tracking sex differences and cognition
and behavior
uh as they are related to the sex
differences in height
so suggesting you know as as I mentioned
you know populations get healthier sex
differences and height get bigger if
there are other biologically based sex
differences or related to you know the
health of the brain for instance then we
should see other differences in spatial
abilities verbal abilities memory
abilities and so forth emerging so I
work on that on I've been working on
off and on on that for for a long time
and it's hard to get
um kind of knock out evidence for it but
there's something there I I just you
know the the data isn't quite there but
I I I have a number of articles on sex
Pacific
um vulnerabilities based on evolutionary
theory and basic biology that you know
if anybody emails me I'm happy to send
David I really appreciate you thank you
so much for today great thank you thank
you I I really enjoyed it what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
me
ant